walk him to this video playing GD down
let's see show us guys play I played him
before g6 is uncommon this is some
actually a weird version of the of the
groom felt always thought this isn't
playable
blood doesn't even get the pole I think
now maybe this way you get the part okay
93 then or is this something better
you're just not see three
yeah this looks like a relatively normal
green felt but he's got the king or
evade other than that it's a fairly
fairly normal position but this
obviously changes the whole procedure
the whole picture oh if you want to not
show I'm just hoping that he cannot take
hindi form maybe again I really would
have tried to make that work as black
d for if yeah probably
I'm not sure maybe you could have taken
on the phone it's obviously risky but
with a normal moves I you simply cannot
play anymore with the King on a bed with
the castles instead of this this would
be fairly normal breathe also did you
really get what what he was thinking how
I thought that taking assessment dettori
anyway okay but what's now rook takes or
pawn takes rook takes us better
attacking the Queen so maybe h4 with
Bishop h3 threatened
still Bishop H or Bishop c5 okay this
isn't bad but this is the best move
Bishop c4 is also very attractive
I just retreat him and don't not sure
Bishop c5 also looks strong hard too
hard to decide it's a truly attractive
came today this also threatens bishop h3
know Andrew t7 this is very strong at
least I hope
yeah bb6 I can even take at Bishop h3
and then rock t7 should win at least the
Queen four pieces
yeah let's keep it simple this should be
enough with Ruby 7 yeah I didn't
calculate that because it looks like it
shouldn't work but maybe I should have
calculated it
I can't come on just take it his king is
a wide open
who came if I take ye 6 he will play
Queen yet check probably not sure that I
want dad
yeah come on I just need another loop
here and then it should be a really
really strong attack like here look g7
coming
check
check
don't tell me there's no maid okay okay
I can do that Jack let's check again I
can check here King edge for and no mate
really I can I have this one I have this
one I can actually do that even wait you
can take age three just just a second
Jack I can't a catch them well I thought
through key for but then you can
actually take h three okay Wow yeah this
is simply a um a bad version of the
groom fault he he has nowhere no decent
way to to capture to get the ball back
now after after this for Knight b6 h3 is
very strong the problem is he cannot
hear didn't have a night to take on c3
and this kind of position is quite quite
good for white it's actually a bit
similar to the bishop d2 line of the
Greenfeld early Bishop e2 but here what
is essentially a tempo up and the tempo
is quite something here and then the
game after this screen a for you you
don't get the bomb back and this is just
too terrible maybe maybe you should have
tried to take the pole I mean it's not
it's not so clear
I mean hear this I wasn't really sure
what I would play then yeah the computer
likes it for black the problem is I need
to take here also and here yeah you
actually have kinky 7 and repair the-the
sport castling yeah i probably made some
mistake here probably need to play d5
here yeah this is better and now a
normal move there should be two on or
something alright thanks for watching